[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
So wonderful to see you.
Thank you for braving
the rain to be here
on this very special evening.
I'm Tomiko Brown-Nagin,
the Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced
Study at Harvard University.
Welcome to the biannual
Rama S. Mehta lecture,
which focuses our attention
on topics related to women
in the developing world.
This lectureship was established
in Rama Mehta's memory
by Catherine Atwater Galbraith
and John Kenneth Galbraith,
along with the Mehta family.
The lecture is supported
by the Harvard Radcliffe
Class of 1973, through the
Benazir Bhutto leadership
program.
So let me extend a
special thanks to them.
I'm also happy to welcome all
the members of the Harvard
Radcliffe classes of 1973, 1978,
and 1988, who are celebrating
reunions this week.
I'm also grateful to the members
of the Radcliffe Institute
Leadership Society, and all
our dedicated annual donors.
Thank you.
This afternoon, we
have the pleasure
of hearing from NPR
international correspondent,
Ofeibea Quist-Arcton,
live and in person,
rather than over the radio.
[LAUGHTER]
The title of Ofeibea's lecture
is both a statement of fact
and a call to action.
The voices of African women
and girls matter deeply,
and far too often,
they go unheard.
But it's not just the women
and girls' voices that are
excluded.
It's also what we
find in their place
that we need to worry about.
It's not a coincidence that
we're often presented with,
and sometimes too
easily persuaded by,
a distorted view of
the African continent.
A view that's narrowly focused
on conflict, corruption,
and disease.
A view that's devoid of
the nuance and complexity
we expect in other contexts.
And a view that's
frequently just plain wrong.
In 2015, President Barack
Obama visited Nairobi, Kenya
to co-host a summit on
global entrepreneurship.
The choice of location
wasn't an accident.
Nairobi was then,
and is now, a hub
of entrepreneurial
innovation in East Africa.
And it boasts an
inspiring community
of women entrepreneurs.
Yet, one prominent news
network covered the visit
under the banner headline,
Obama's trip to Kenya--
a Terror Hotbed.
The article itself
wasn't much better.
Tired and damaging cliches
about the African continent
are not limited
to the news media.
During the 2014 World
Cup, an American airline
tweeted their congratulations
to the US team
for its win over Ghana.
The airline represented
the United States
with the Statue of Liberty,
an iconic national symbol
and a representation
of universal freedom.
For Ghana, a West
African democracy
with a population larger
than Australia's, they
used a giraffe.
The first problem is that
Ghana doesn't have giraffes--
[LAUGHTER]
--a fact that the Twitterverse
was quick to point out.
But we also should
ask ourselves,
what it is in our discourse
that would lead a marketing
team to turn to any stock
image of a wild animal
to represent an African country?
These kinds of
characterizations both reflect
and fuel widespread
misperceptions
about the African
continent, which
is home to over 1.2 billion
people across 54 countries,
including 14 that achieved
economic growth rates above 5%
last year.
It's the work of dedicated,
thoughtful journalists
like Ofeibea
Quist-Arcton that disrupt
this pattern by focusing on the
important, nuanced stories that
often go uncovered, and by
amplifying the voices of women,
girls, and others we're
least likely to hear,
whether due to oversight,
unconscious bias,
or overt discrimination.
Ofeibea's is a familiar
and a trusted voice,
and one that many of us
will immediately recognize.
She neither forgoes complexity
for clarity, nor clarity
for complexity.
As NPR's Africa
reporter, Ofeibea
covers social and political
developments, the arts,
culture, technology,
and so much more.
The breadth of her knowledge
and of her work is exceptional.
And a consistent thread
in Ofeibea's reporting
is the foregrounding of
lesser-known stories,
and those of women and girls.
Ofeibea received the 2015
Edward R Murrow award
for outstanding contributions
to public radio,
including her coverage of
Boko Haram's kidnapping
and exploitation of girls,
which has continued long
after the international
spotlight dimmed.
She also was a part of
the team of NPR reporters
who received a
2014 Peabody Award
for their coverage of the
Ebola outbreak in West Africa.
Before joining NPR, Ofeibea
reported for the BBC
on flagship programs in
radio and television,
and covered 24 countries, as
head of the BBC's West Africa
bureau.
She also had a stint here in
Cambridge as a roving North
American reporter for
Public Radio International's
The World.
I'll welcome Ofeibea to
the stage in just a moment.
After the lecture, she'll
be joined in conversation
by another award-winning
journalist, Marco Werman, who
began his radio
career in West Africa
and has hosted The
World since 2013.
Five times a week,
Marco brings world news
into our homes, our
cars, and our earbuds
of Public Radio listeners across
the United States and Canada.
Like Ofeibea, he's committed
to amplifying less-heard voices
and little-known stories.
I'm so glad Marco is
here with us, too.
Now, please join me in
welcoming Ofeibea Quist-Arcton.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good evening, friends.
Why didn't you talk to the
weather gods on my behalf?
[LAUGHTER]
Greetings.
Greetings from West Africa, from
Dakar, where I'm based from,
Ghana, where I come from,
from the whole continent.
That is such a
spectacular continent.
Thank you very much, Tomiko.
What a wonderful,
wonderful welcome for us.
And it's super to be
back here in Cambridge,
where I spent a couple of years
and learnt all sorts of snowy
language, like a sprinkling
of snow, and digging out.
I haven't forgotten, but I don't
miss the snow and the cold.
Thanks, all, for
coming this evening.
Wonderful to see you.
Yes, African women,
African girls--
what they have to
say is important,
but we don't hear enough of it.
And I blame myself
amongst reporters
for not reporting enough
about these important views.
Women hold up half the sky.
I believe that's what
Mao Zedong once said.
And it's so true.
So true.
Yet, too often, women
still do not get their due.
And that's the world over.
Africa-- the continent I come
from and where I report from--
is no exception.
We're working on it.
When Congolese gynecologist
surgeon Dr. Denis Mukwege,
was announced with fellow
Yazidi activist Nadia
Morad as the latest co-recipient
of the Nobel Peace Prize,
at last, a week ago,
it was heartening
to see dozens of
women and young girls
cheering and ululating outside
his Panzi Hospital in Bukavu
in eastern Congo.
Dr. Mukwege-- who has literally
surgically been fixing,
for 20-plus years, women's
vaginas after they've survived
sexual violence, rape and
fistula complications--
was conducting his second
operation of the day
when the news filtered through
that the Nobel Committee had
chosen him as a co-laureate
of the annual Peace Prize.
The women, especially
of eastern Congo,
immediately owned that honor
along with Dr. Mukwege.
Dr. Miracle, Dr.
Miracle, they call him.
The man who has, through
reconstructive surgery,
stitched and repaired the damage
inflicted on women and girls
who have been sexually violated
by rival armed men in conflicts
in the phenomenon now dubbed
rape as a weapon of war.
Damage to their bodies
and their psyche.
These women feel now that
their pain, their suffering,
and their troubles are
being acknowledged and taken
seriously.
So in a perverse
sort of way, perhaps
they have triumphed with
this Nobel endorsement
of the work of Dr.
Mukwege and his team,
as well as a myriad women
supporters, survivors,
of sexual violence, and others.
There are, no doubt, some of the
same Congolese women who gather
together their meager resources
in a potentially wealthy
but pitifully poor country,
where the coltan used
to manufacture the smartphone--
which is perhaps in your pocket
right now-- where it's mined--
they paid for a plane
ticket to bring home Dr.
Mukwege from overseas,
where he had taken refuge
from eastern Congo.
That was after he was
driven into exile by threats
to his family and to him.
He was forced to stop his work
as a gynecologist and outspoken
campaigner for women's rights.
The women wanted Dr.
Miracle back home
to continue his hugely
important surgical work
and his unswerving,
unwavering support,
and they made it happen,
through their solidarity,
their determination, and,
yes, their love and admiration
for him.
I mention the women and girls
of Bukavu in eastern Congo
because these are the very
people I look for and seek out
when I'm reporting in Africa.
And we don't hear enough
about or from them.
So you've got to cut through
the lines of eager young men who
zoom up to your microphone--
all with their views, opinions,
grievances, and, of course,
their aspirations.
Of course their views matter.
I'm not saying they don't.
But push back the masses.
Part those clamoring to talk
and dominate the conversation.
Walk through the crowds
beyond the thrusting youth,
to the back.
And that's where you'll find
the women in the compound,
or behind the pots
and market stalls,
with babies strapped to their
backs, with colorful cloth,
and husbands to keep happy.
They're busy.
They have to work, and they
have families to provide for.
They don't have time to go
rushing up to reporters.
But they know what's going on.
They're not just talking,
or seeking out journalists.
They're listening, and
assessing, and monitoring.
Make the effort to find
these women, and sometimes
younger women and girls
too, because they, too,
have a story to tell.
Give them time,
spend time with them,
and it may well be a different
story you'll find to the one
the young men rushed to share
with you in the first flush
of reporting.
You must make the effort
to find these other voices.
It's what I try to do.
Like Dr. Mukwege's mainly
women patients and supporters,
you can sometimes be
surprised, astonished,
by what they have to tell you.
This year's Nobel
Peace Prize winners,
as a dear friend
puts it, reminds us
of women throughout
the ages who've
been used as ways of
punishing men and communities.
Or, used for victory
celebrations as the trophies
of marauding men.
Let me give you one
example-- nine years ago,
we rushed to Guinea--
Guinea Conakry-- on
the West African coast.
After hearing that human
rights and peace campaigners,
including many
women, had gathered
in the national stadium
in the capital Conakry,
they had come under
a hail of gunfire
by soldiers trying to stop them
gathering and demonstrating.
This happened under
the short-lived watch
of the military leader
Captain Moussa Dadis Camara.
What later emerged was, as
one doctor told journalists,
her voice trembling,
a view echoed
by many, many other
Guineans we spoke to--
C'est du jamais vu.
This is unheard of in Guinea.
Unprecedented.
Never before have we witnessed
such brutal acts, she told.
The doctor said, I have never
seen such violence in my life.
This is the first
time we have witnessed
women's bodies being treated
like battlefields in Guinea.
It goes against our
culture and traditions.
I am horrified.
Familiar reports spoke of men
in uniform reeking of alcohol,
and high on other substances.
Whether they were hired guns,
homemade presidential red
berries, or rogue soldiers,
as Dadis, the unelected head
of state, would have
us believe, they
were armed and
looking for trouble.
Women protesters became
their target that day.
The shocking trend
of sexual assault
on women by uniformed
men wielding power
had landed in
Guinea that Monday.
There were horrifying
reports of soldiers
using rifle butts, even
bayonets, to rape women,
while other women,
stripped of their clothing
and their dignity, were
violated, humiliated, raped,
right there in the stadium by
the security forces, brazenly
and brutally, in broad daylight.
But when I look back to my
reporting of the troubles
in Guinea, which had political
problems, and still have,
I remembered the
fearless, diminutive
in size, and the giant in
courage, trade union leader,
labor leader Hajah
Rabiatou Serah
Diallo, With her quiet
authority and steely gaze
staring down soldiers
sent to intimidate her
and other rights and
labor campaigners,
she courageously led marches
demanding sweeping government
reforms, and the military
back to barracks,
insisting there could
be no dialogue in Guinea
until the state of siege, as
she called it, was lifted.
Hajah Rabiatou warned that the
army, with its unlimited powers
of search and detention,
was perpetrating
all manner of evil, committed
under the cover of darkness,
and that individuals were using
this time to rob others, rape
women, and commit
other atrocities.
It has to stop, she pleaded.
This is really very
serious indeed.
Another woman leading the way.
A year later, in 2009,
it was in this climate
of fear, intimidation,
and repression described
by Haja Rabiatou that
women in Guinea's capital
were raped, robbed,
and sexually assaulted
with guns by soldiers.
This is where, as a reporter,
you cannot simply jet
in and, after being parachuted
in for, say, 48 hours,
do the story, cover
the fallout, fly out.
And I thank NPR
for allowing us--
NPR's reporters-- the
time and the space
to be able to report
stories deeply and fully.
It's so important.
So I had to find out more.
Who were these women who had
left their homes in the morning
to attend a protest
march starting
at Conakry Stadium on a Monday?
I'm not a full-time
investigative journalist.
I'm a jobbing journalist.
An all-purpose Africa
reporter, I describe myself as.
I will try to turn
my hand to any story.
You'll find me in
open-air markets,
which I love, talking
to the women who
make Africa's
economies tick, and who
are, for me, the real barometer
of a nation and a continent.
Market women in Africa are like
taxi drivers here in the West--
they know what's
going on and have
an informed opinion on almost
everything that matters.
I certainly listen to them.
They're full of advice
and timely guidance.
And everybody who knows Ofeibea
knows, I'm a bit of a shopper.
[LAUGHTER]
Nowhere better than the
market, exchanging everything
from compliments about
a Nigerian batik,
as I'm wearing tonight, or
Senegalese or Ghanian woven
fabric, or Ghanian colorful
kente I might be wearing,
or her printed wax
cloth, or sometimes
spontaneously exchanging gifts.
I love jewelry.
I love it chunky.
And it's wonderful
to be able to share
a love of Africa's beauty, be it
a design or a creative fabric.
In South Africa,
they call it ubuntu--
a shared humanity.
And sharing something
beyond measure,
but it's an exchange
that can suddenly
make what might have been
a tricky interview doable.
Why?
Because you found a link that
you have in common, and you're
away.
I can also be found on the
front line reporting conflicts,
or in the boardroom, talking
to the continent's women
movers and shakers, creators,
innovators, and inventors,
or, in educational institutions,
urban and village settings.
I'll give everything a go.
Why not?
You'll find me in creative
spaces or sacred places,
listening to women, and
girls, and men, and boys,
talk to us reporters.
Talk to each other
and to many others
about their communities, the
continent, the world, and what
matters to them.
I think, to be a
good reporter, you've
got to be a good listener.
But sometimes, as in Guinea
in 2009, it isn't so simple.
The horror of the
shocking attacks
on women who were raped
in the open by soldiers
affected the entire nation,
but that was not the end.
A number of women, some of whom
I later found and spoke to,
were marched off to
a villa somewhere,
and the horror continued.
It took time to
find these women,
going through an
intermediary who
was herself terrified
that she would
be discovered and punished.
Eventually, I met
some of the women
in a small room in a
safe house in Guinea,
which is a country where it
is totally shameful to talk
about taboo subjects such
as rape or sexual violence.
So these women have not been
able to discuss their ordeal
with even family members,
or they were too frightened
to even consult doctors,
yet they had been raped.
One woman, a gently-spoken
professional,
told me she was praying she
hadn't been infected with HIV,
or wasn't pregnant,
after the hell she'd
endured once they were
taken away from the stadium.
She described how the
soldiers had driven them
to a villa where
they were drugged
and didn't know where they were.
She hadn't been able
to discuss all this
with her sister, her husband,
or any family member or friend.
Why?
I asked.
Out of shame, she replied.
She only managed to escape when
a soldier walked into the room,
probably to join in, she said.
Only to realize
that he knew her.
He got her out.
The courage of these
women to share their hell
with a journalist like me--
someone they did not know
and had never met before--
was, for me, proof of immense
and immeasurable bravery.
To tell others that this
was happening in Guinea,
where the rule of law
had been jettisoned,
abandoned, and they felt their
nation and the world must know.
I know we journalists
stand accused
of focusing far too much on
conflict, disease, poverty--
the negatives about Africa
that Tomiko mentioned.
Mea maxima culpa.
I agree.
But we have to tell Africa's
truth, good and bad.
Pretty and sad.
Ugly and enriching.
And women are often the
holders of these truths.
Of course, there are many,
many, many positive stories--
powerful, influential,
inspiring, strong, creative,
resourceful, resilient,
charming, compassionate,
fabulous African women
and girls abound.
African crown jewels,
they are treasures.
And they're taking the
world by storm, all quietly,
getting things done and making
a difference and a change
to the lives of girls,
women, boys, and men.
Girls are coding, and they're
loving it, and building
smartphone apps that help
reunite children who've got
lost, reuniting them
with their families.
Women innovators in Africa are
making a difference 24/7, be it
in technology, the arts,
music, literature, publishing.
They're setting up bespoke
chocolate enterprises
on the continent, where
most of the world's cocoa,
probably used to make
your favorite choccy bar,
is produced.
Cote d'Ivoire, Ghana,
are some examples.
They're doing even more.
Take the 2011 Nobel
Peace joint winners,
Africa's first elected
female president,
Ellen Johnson
Sirleaf from Liberia,
and her compatriot,
Leymah Gbowee,
who led the Women in White
protest campaign and marches
during Liberia's
protracted civil war.
Civil wars, In fact.
Or another Nobel Peace laureate,
the late Kenyan environmental
and political activist
Wangari Maathai,
who campaigned tirelessly for
a better Kenya and Africa.
Then there are the names
you may not know so well--
national treasures
like Hauwa Magaji,
a psychosocial councilor
from northeast Nigeria.
She comes from Chibok, a town
you've probably heard of,
where the mass abduction
of nearly 300 schoolgirls
by the extremist group Boko
Haram happened back in 2014.
Hauwa Magaji moved from
Chibok to Maiduguri,
the regional hub
in the northeast,
to help young girls and women--
many barely in their
teens at the time
they were captured and sexually
enslaved by Boko Haram--
to help them reintegrate
into society.
Many of these women
and young, young teens
are being rejected
or marginalized
by their families
and communities
when they return with babies
fathered by Boko Haram
fighters.
Their babies are dubbed
Boko Haram babies,
and they Boko Haram wives.
Talking of Chibok, in my
almost 35 years as a reporter,
one of the most
uplifting assignments
I can remember to
date was covering
students who were abducted from
their girls' boarding school
dorms in Chibok, reuniting
with their families in Abuja,
Nigeria last year.
Here's one such photo.
Not half an hour earlier, we
were trying to comfort her.
She couldn't find her parents.
So many of the other young
women who had been released
were hugging and crying.
She said, my parents are dead.
My parents are--
she was hysterical,
thinking that her
parents were dead.
They said to her, no.
They've just had a
problem with the car.
They're on their way.
And when she saw her parents,
she sank to the ground,
weeping.
And half an hour later, there
she was with her friends.
They were singing and dancing.
Look at her.
It was an extraordinary,
extraordinary event,
watching this reunion.
Sometimes, as a reporter,
love is on your side,
and you're in the right
place at the right time.
I was lucky that day.
Happened to be in
Abuja and to cover
this remarkable, remarkable
story of families
who had been through pain,
the agony of separation.
It ended there, the tears.
Fathers, mothers, daughters,
hugging and weeping,
and weeping and hugging.
There was barely a
dry eye, me included.
After three years with
barely any contact,
families were reunited in
relief and thanksgiving.
The joy was palpable.
Everyone present felt blessed.
But spare a thought
for Leah Sharibu, who
was 15 when she was abducted
from Dapchi Girls' Technical
College in northeast
Nigeria earlier this year.
Dozens of her fellow students
were bundled off by Boko Haram.
President Muhammadu
Buhari's government
negotiated an early release
of most of the abducted girls,
but we are told that
Leah Sharibu, the only
Christian among mainly
Muslim girls kidnapped,
refused to renounce
Christianity.
While the others have been
released, Leah has not.
When we traveled to Dapchi
on assignment in March,
we met Leah's mother Rebecca.
We only found out
that her daughter
had been abducted in
Dapchi when we sat down
on a mat in the dusty square
in front of the emir's palace
with a group of
women and mothers
from the community
to find out more.
Leah is still missing.
So my advice is, take
the time to talk.
You will make contacts
that may prove
to be invaluable, as in this
case of the Sharibu family.
We've kept in touch with
Mr. And Mrs. Sharibu.
Just last week, the
Nigerian president
called up Leah's
mother to again pledge
that he will do all he can to
bring her daughter back safely
from Boko Haram captivity.
Working your
contacts is crucial,
but it makes such
a difference when
you have met the
person with whom
you're talking about
sensitive, painful, often
difficult topics.
This portrait of reporting
on women and girls in Africa
is somewhat scattershot.
I've picked on some
of the examples that
have stayed with
me of why I find
it's critical to reflect the
importance of women and girls
in Africa.
I guess I gravitate
towards them,
because there are so
many untold stories,
perhaps because
we, the reporters,
don't dig deep enough.
A couple of years ago, I
met documentary photographer
and chronicler Fati
Abubakar in Maiduguri,
the birthplace of Boko Haram,
and the capital of Borno State
in northeast Nigeria.
She trained as a nurse
and worked as a nurse.
Fati said she was frustrated
and fed up with out
of towners like me--
I didn't take it
personally, though--
painting such a negative
picture of her home state
and its ties with
the extremist group.
So she set up on Instagram,
and Twitter, and Facebook,
and posts extraordinary
portraits of Borno
under the hashtag bits of Borno.
She photographs random
people, children.
She says they make her smile.
Women, men, you name it.
Fati Abubakar is
determined to give us
a rounded picture
of Borno that she
says the local and
international media
neglect, choosing to focus on
bomb blasts, suicide attacks,
death, and destruction.
It's wonderful to
watch Fati at work.
She's dainty, and wears long,
colorful, elegant dresses,
with her camera slung
over her shoulder,
squatting and leaning
perilously close to the railing
separating her and the road
from a three-foot plunge
into a trash dump.
She's inspiring.
She doesn't seem to see it.
She just bends down
her skirts in the dust,
and, snap, snap, snap, snap.
Then out comes her notebook.
Note, note, note, note.
And then she posts these
extraordinary pictures.
Hashtag bits of Borno.
Look her up.
Let me conclude with an
assignment in South Africa
in April this year that
could have been sorrowful
if it hadn't been
such a celebration
of the remarkable life of
Winnie Madikizela-Mandela.
Mourners, female and
male, adults and children,
were everywhere, and
they were weeping openly.
In many ways, the Winnie story
crystallizes precisely why
the voices of women
and girls matter.
It was extraordinary to witness,
on the ground after she died,
the full impact and effect of
her influence and inspiration
over the years.
Women and girls-- especially
black, South African,
young women and girls--
just burst forth with
grief and gratitude,
thanking Winnie Mandela for
her enormous contribution
to the struggle for
freedom in South Africa,
despite the negatives
and the lows in her life.
And there were many.
Almost every girl
and woman I spoke to
talked about what Winnie
Mandela meant to them.
They said they now understood
what it is to be a woman
in South Africa-- in Africa--
living in a mainly,
predominantly patriarchal
society.
Movements mushroomed.
And especially
for younger women,
the passing of Winnie
Madikizela-Mandela spurred
the mantra, she didn't die.
She multiplied.
They donned dhukus,
head wraps, as they're
called in South Africa,
that Madikizela-Mandela
made her trademark and
joined the hashtag,
I am Winnie, movement.
Wearing a fetching and
simple Winnie-style head tie
when I met her outside Mrs.
Madikizela-Mandela's Soweto
home, a 22-year-old
student, Neo Ngcobo,
said she had joined the
flourishing, unofficial
movements.
My Ma Winnie didn't die.
She did indeed
multiply, said Neo,
adding, because what
she left us with
is the spirit to fight for what
we want as women, especially
as young women.
Neo said there were many
challenges facing young South
Africans, but that
Winnie Mandela had
given all young
women the inspiration
to get up and fight for what
they really want in life.
Women empowerment, she said,
and lifting each other up.
This, said Neo, is exactly what
we mean by, she did not die.
She multiplied.
Neo's shy, 10-year-old
sister, Andisiwe,
was also proudly
wearing a Winnie dhuku,
and said she, too, was inspired
as a South African girl,
adding, I respect and love her.
Rest in peace, Mama.
And the incredibly
articulate 22-year-old Neo--
I mean, it just summed
up what the feeling
in South Africa in Johannesburg
during Winnie Mandela's
funeral, and that period.
Young women were
standing up and saying,
our voices must be heard.
And then you have this
10-year-old also adding
her contribution.
In a eulogy to her mother
during her funeral,
Winnie Mandela's daughter
Zenani Mandela-Dlamini
made a point of thanking young
South Africans, especially
young women,
saying, as a family,
they had watched in awe as
young women stood up and took
a stand of deep solidarity
with their mother, who
had been judged, she said,
by much harsher standards
than her male counterparts.
A dear South African friend,
the BBC's Audrey Brown,
with whom I covered
Winnie Mandela's funeral,
put it this way.
She said, an understanding
of how "Wee-nee,"
as they call her there, was
terrorized as a woman alone--
a young woman alone--
and slandered as a
beautiful woman--
came roaring out of the grief
people felt at her passing.
There's something pretty
special about witnessing history
and reporting it.
And there's something equally
special about recording
what women and girls
have to say about it all.
I guess that's why
I do the job I do.
It's an honor and a privilege.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, sir.
Good.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- Wonderful comments,
inspiring and wise.
Thank you, Ofeibea.
And thank you to the
Radcliffe Institute
for giving me the
honor and the pleasure
to speak with, honestly,
an old dear friend, and one
of my favorite people
in the whole world.
And I mean that from
the bottom of my heart.
So we've known each
other a long time.
I want to get
personal in a second,
but I just want to pick
up on a couple of things
that you said in your talk.
The women in Guinea
that you spoke with--
I mean, there are very few
people who can go in a room
and sit down with
women who've been
through that kind of trauma--
with anybody who's been
and get them to open up.
You talked about
their courage, but I
think, especially in this
day and age, when journalists
are not really appreciated by
governments around the world,
it takes a lot of courage to,
A, go in to speak with them--
but also, I want to know how you
kind of frame your own attitude
and your own psyche.
Because not everybody
can go in that room
and get the kind of
responses that you get.
So what is it about you,
Ofeibea, that allows people--
these women, these girls--
who've been through so much--
traumatized to the point that
life itself seems futile--
what do you do?
What do you say to
get them to open up?
And what is it about you
that makes them talk?
- Well one thing
you don't do is,
you don't breeze in and
say, I've got 10 minutes.
[LAUGHTER]
Cough up.
No, I mean, this is why I say,
you've really got to take time.
Before I met the women--
before I met them
to interview them--
I had been there a few hours.
I had been there the day before.
People have got to
get used to you.
They don't know you.
What do they know?
They don't know what
you're going to be saying.
So you know, Marco, I
met some of the students
from the colleges at lunchtime.
And I said, I think the
most important thing is,
you've got to show compassion.
You've got to show compassion.
If you're only interested in
these women, or girls, or men,
or boys, because of the
story you're going to get,
they may not speak to you.
People are instinctive.
They know if you're
only coming for a story,
or if you really care about
what they have been through.
So some people weren't able
to give their full story.
There was one woman who
talked in the third person.
She was in the
stadium, and she talked
as if she had seen someone
else being violated and raped.
And the go between who helped
me set up these interviews later
said to me, she was actually
talking about herself.
But she's so ashamed
about this taboo,
and there were
other women around.
She didn't want them to
know she had been raped.
If you don't empathize,
what's the point?
Somebody said to me, well,
don't you get empathy fatigue?
I said, the day I
have empathy fatigue,
I stop being a reporter.
- I mean, that's a great
bar to hold up, but, I mean,
so much of journalism is about
competition, and getting it
first, but getting it
right, but getting it first.
Nobody talks about, get
it first, get it right,
and be compassionate and
empathetic along the way.
So how many people--
how many journalists in Africa--
have all those qualities?
- Oh my god.
[LAUGHTER]
I think you have a lot of
compassionate journalists,
but you also have those who
just go for the jugular.
And they're not
really interested.
And I think it maybe
shows in the reporting.
They may get stock answers.
They may get answers
that you might expect.
But if you give people time
to get to know you a little--
and I'm not saying they're
going to know me for a month,
or three months, no--
but even for a full
day or a week--
people get a bit
more comfortable.
And then they feel
that they can tell you
more because, hopefully,
they trust you a little.
It's so important.
I put myself in their positions.
Would I talk to
somebody I didn't know?
If it was Marco, and I knew
him, I would feel confident.
But somebody who comes
out of nowhere asking you
such personal questions?
I think we owe it
to those people who
are sharing such intimate
and difficult details with us
to give them that compassion.
- I mean, I know it's
no problem for you,
when you go to the
back of the mob
and you find the women
in the marketplace.
I mean, I've seen
you in the field.
I've seen you in action.
You're just a natural.
I mean, you are one of them.
Do you see it that way?
- Of course I am, because
I'm an African woman.
But I think more
importantly, I mean,
you can do all the
reporting from here
with the people
in the front row.
But what about
those at the back?
[LAUGHTER]
If you only interview
people in the front row,
you'll get front row
comments the whole time.
But if you dig a bit
deeper and go to--
you'll see people that you
wouldn't, perhaps, even
expect to be listening
to what's going on,
because they're busy, as I said.
But they're there.
And sometimes you say hello.
You sit down.
You ask after their
family and their children.
And, boop!
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe, they say,
this is somebody
who's actually interested
in me, and in my life,
and in my family.
- So you brought up the fact
that the Nobel Peace Prize
this week went to Dr. Denis
Mukwege and to Nadia Morad,
for their work fighting
rape as a weapon of war.
And in Dr. Mukwege's case--
Dr. Miracle-- I mean, his
ability, not only as a surgeon,
but also to bring these women
back around from trauma--
Your talk was about
women, but I want
to know about men in Africa.
And how many men are looking at
somebody like Dr. Denis Mukwege
and are saying, I
want to be like him.
I want to be a
better man for women.
How many men do
you find in Africa
who are leaning
in that direction?
I know this is a
massive generalization.
I know you don't
like generalizations.
I'm going to put you
on the spot anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
Where do men stand on this?
And how are men changing?
- The rapists see him
as a threat, and not
just the rapists--
the government of Congo.
They don't like Denis Mukwege.
He had to hotfoot it out
of eastern Congo because
of threats on his life,
and the life of his family.
His bodyguard was killed.
- But was that because
he was essentially
trying a sop against
fighters in the military?
And they didn't like that?
Or because he was
focusing on helping women?
- Both.
Both.
Of course there are men
who sympathize, many men.
They may not come
out and say it.
And there again,
Marco, maybe that's
for me to go and
find out from them.
What do you think of the
work of Denis Mukwege?
You feel it enhances
the community?
Or do you feel that it
brings shame to the community
that this has happened?
Of course I speak to men.
I speak to young men.
I speak to older men.
I just think that they get more
of a voice in Africa-- in fact,
all over the world--
than women and girls.
So I make a special effort to
hear more from women and girls.
But I speak to men.
I speak to them about
difficult subjects.
I spoke to men after
the rapes in Guinea.
I mean, some of them couldn't
stop the tears from flowing,
because they witnessed it, too.
It wasn't just women who
saw women being raped.
What do you do
when you can't help
somebody who is being violated?
You must feel not only helpless,
but, in a way, redundant.
Why couldn't I help?
Why couldn't I grab a
machete or a bayonet,
and stop the soldiers from
doing what they were doing?
We do come from
patriarchal societies.
So men are expected to protect,
be it a woman, be it children.
So it's a tough call.
- Let's update the
situation in Chibok
just briefly, because
you talked about how
joyous the celebration was,
the reuniting of these girls
with their families.
You spoke briefly about
how some of these girls
were being rejected.
Their children that they
birthed after being impregnated
by the Boko Haram militants--
how they're being rejected.
We recently, on the program,
spoke with Adaobi Tricia
Nwaubani about some of the
girls who are now at university,
and getting these bourses.
But they're also having trouble.
So where does this all go?
I mean, what does life look like
for these girls in the future?
- We'll only know in
the future, Marco.
Those who are able to
go back to education,
at least they will
have an education.
And I spoke only briefly,
but I have reported
at length on young women--
they're no longer girls,
because they are 18, 19, 20.
- Right.
- But if you go back five
years when they were abducted,
they were 13, 14, 15.
Because those who have children
often say that has saved them.
Because, even though
their families,
even though the
community, may reject them
they have someone to love.
And they have
someone to protect.
But I don't think they're
under any illusions
that life is going
to be difficult.
- Are their social
workers and psychologists
that attend to them?
Because I know a lot of
people that I met in Africa
rejected talk therapy.
But Dr. Mukwege's
experience shows
that it's obviously helpful in
an universal kind of context.
- Indeed, and Hauwa
Magaji, who I spoke about--
- Right.
- --the psychosocial counselor,
who moved from Chibok,
where she comes from--
these are precisely the
African men and women
who are trying to help
not only the young women
reintegrate into society, but
the communities to accept them,
saying, you can't
punish them twice.
They didn't ask to be raped.
They didn't ask to be
abducted by Boko Haram.
Look what they
have been through.
If anything, we the
community should
be welcoming them with open
arms and saying, sorry.
So they're working
with those who
have been affected
and have survived,
and also with those
who are finding
it difficult to accept these--
and not just young women,
sometimes children.
Yeah, because they're seen as
being tainted by Boko Haram.
It's tough.
And you have other
organizations,
like the Neem Foundation.
There is a Nigerian psychologist
who trained outside.
And she said she got
into psychology because
of the big cases that
were happening here
in the US and Britain.
And she was with
the government--
the previous government, now,
has set up this foundation.
They're trying.
But it's difficult, because
these are such taboo subjects
that a lot of people
don't want to touch them.
- Bring back our girls.
Big hashtag.
What about me too, as a
hashtag, as a movement.
What does it mean to
the women and girls
that you've met
in the last year?
- Women in urban
areas have caught on,
because everybody is on
social media except Ofeibea.
[LAUGHTER]
- This is true.
It's maddening, but it's true.
- Everybody is on social media.
So in a different way, I think
me too has had an effect.
In many African
countries, I think
it has given especially
young women a voice
to stand up and say, no.
We're not going to
put up with this.
And that really maybe
isn't the African way.
You don't challenge your elders
because of the respect factor.
And I think respect is good.
But now, more questions
are being asked.
More pressure is
being put on people
who use power in this way.
And young people are saying no.
But on the other hand,
you have the phenomenon
of the sugar daddy--
other names-- who are
financing young women who
are maybe at university,
or college, or even school.
- That's very common.
- Finanacing their studies.
So it's a real contradiction,
because you have me too.
And we stand up for our rights.
But if somebody is paying
your education for sex,
that's a tough one.
Unresolved.
- I should say that Ofeibea
and I have known each other
since 1987, and it's not
like you went to Africa
and carved out this niche of
women and girls for yourself.
The first time we met was on
the phone a couple of months
after Captain Thomas
Sankara had been killed
as president of Burkina Faso.
And Ofeibea was hosting
Network Africa, the breakfast
show for the African continent
on the BBC World Service.
And I was the AP
stringer in Ouagadougou,
and you wanted to do an
interview on a piece of cloth
that was going around.
Les larmes de Mariam.
The tears of Mariam, The
widow of Thomas Sankara.
Mariam Sankara.
And it was a
shocking coup d'etat.
Nobody had ever seen a bloody
coup d'etat in ex Upper
Volta, Burkina Faso before.
And so people were really
scared to speak out.
And one of the ways they
spoke out was through cloth.
- Wearing this--
- This cloth with peppers.
- Specially printed cloth.
- Little peppers, and
it looked like tears.
So it was called
the tears of Miriam.
And that's when we spoke.
But I want to kind
of pick up there,
because we want to know the
more personal side of Ofeibea.
We know Dakar.
[LAUGHTER]
You do it.
Come on.
[APPLAUSE]
- Shall I tell you
how that started?
It was this--
[LAUGHTER]
There's Dhaka, Bangladesh.
Then there's Dakar, Senegal.
Well, people were saying it
as if it was the same capital.
And I said, no.
Hell no.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm happy to report
from Dhaka, Bangladesh,
but that's not where I am.
So I think I started
emphasizing--
[LAUGHTER]
And the rest is history.
It's a wonderful city.
Come and visit.
[LAUGHTER]
Lovely place to live.
Yeah.
- So there's the reporter
that we Americans know,
and then there's
the other Ofeibea.
And I just want to
dive into that Ofeibea
for a couple of minutes.
Because with the exception of my
friends [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE]
from college, you were the first
Afropolitan who I'd ever met.
Born in Accra, yes?
- Oxford.
Born in Oxford,
moved back to Accra.
- By coincidence.
- Rome, London-- you're
comfortable in many worlds.
So just tell me about your life.
You're born under this
postcolonial world-- not even,
barely.
When did you first
get to Africa,
and how much back and forth did
you do between Accra and Europe
growing up?
- Let me just say, for a
start, doesn't matter where
you're brought up in the world.
If you've got
Ghanian parents, you
are going to be
brought up Ghanian.
It didn't matter that
we lived in Rome,
that I was born in Oxford.
There are certain
Ghanian things,
and you don't
deviate from those.
And actually, no.
It's been really good.
Because it gives you
roots and an identity,
which is really important.
So although we've lived
in different places,
and I've worked in
different places,
I never have to think
twice if somebody asks me,
where are you from.
Ghana's back home.
Dhaka is Dhaka base.
London is other home.
Cambridge is other home.
[LAUGHTER]
- But I mean, you were traveling
a lot, though, as a girl.
I mean, to Nairobi.
All over the place.
- It's true.
But we went to
school in Britain.
- Right.
- So there was that continuity.
I was born a year after--
I'm 60.
Yeah.
I turned 60 in August.
[APPLAUSE]
So I was born a year after
the end of the colonial rule
in Britain.
And I mean, of
course, I was a baby.
But from the stories we hear,
it was such a happy time,
getting freedom.
So we then went back home.
So I did my nursery
school, would have been.
And then we went
off to live in Rome.
And then--
- Nairobi.
- Your father worked
for forestries--
- My father worked for the UN.
- --under Nkrumah.
But then went to Rome.
- He was the first chief
conservator of forests.
So I guess that gives
me my love of wood.
[LAUGHTER]
It didn't sort of click for a
long while, but I love wood.
- [INAUDIBLE].
- I know we're meant to
be conserving it, but--
- Especially the
tropical woods, right?
- Yes.
Indeed.
Yeah.
But because we were a
family unit wherever.
It didn't really
matter where we were.
And then going home every two
years to Ghana on home leave
meant that we caught up--
our late mother was the
eldest of 10 children.
So we're about 50-odd
cousins, give or take,
and we had a grandmother
we all adored.
So all we all wanted to do
was congregate at her home.
And Ghana has always
been back home.
Your father was
in public service.
I know your aunt
[INAUDIBLE] was ambassador
to Rome, and Paris,
and the Vatican.
Did you ever think
about doing government,
or some sort of public service,
as opposed to journalism?
- I wanted to be a diplomat.
I thought either
diplomat or interpreter.
When I saw the booths that
the interpreters had to--
I said, no.
That's not for me.
[LAUGHTER]
And I think I might have
gone the route of the Foreign
Service.
But Ghana, at the time,
was a military leadership.
And of course you
represent your government.
I didn't feel like I
could quite do that.
Plus, I come from
a political family.
So I thought, you're
weaned on the BBC
if your parents are expatriates
from most of Africa--
- Yeah, World Service.
- Yeah, the BBC World Service.
So that was the
background noise.
And I thought, well,
maybe I could do that.
And that's how it came to be.
- Worked out pretty well.
I'm going to open
it up to the floor,
but I have one more question.
And I know this is such
American exceptionalism.
Let's talk about the
United States for a second.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to do it
because you were
the world's first roving
American correspondent.
I think it was a
fantastic experiment.
And I think now,
more than ever, we
need that kind of-- would
you come back and work
for us again?
I'm--
[LAUGHTER]
--it's just a play for that.
But I think of the demonization
of a free press right now.
The laissez-faire kind
of attitude toward rules,
governing, conflict of
interest, and nepotism,
corruption writ large--
not to mention the casual
attitudes toward women's place
in the world.
We're also watching the
US-Saudi relationship
come to some sort
of inflection point
with the disappearance
and sad possibility
that Jamal Khashoggi
has been killed,
and what that's going to do to
Trump and the Saudi monarchy.
And it doesn't look like Trump
is rushing to pick up the phone
to find out what happened.
So how much of this modeling
in the White House right now
do you think is seeping
into African politics?
And how empowering is it
for authoritarians in Africa
to see what's happening with
Trump in the White House right
now?
- I think if you talk
to African people,
they're wondering
what's going on here.
This isn't the
America they know.
And a lot of the
things happening,
people say, well, hang on.
If that's happening where we
come from, there's criticism.
But I think President
Trump is probably
a [? fillet ?] for a
lot of African leaders
who want to do it their way,
come what may, regardless.
Although President
Trump has only
been in power for two years,
you have Paul Biya in Cameroon.
He's 85.
He was back in elections
at the weekend.
- And those monitors
from transparency
were crisis actors, apparently.
- So people who aren't leaders,
who are not being criticized,
I think are pretty happy
with President Trump.
Apart from his one something
whole countries comment,
and a few others, there
hasn't been much said.
But if his eyes go to
you, and he doesn't
like what you're doing, hey.
Watch out, because
he speaks his mind.
But for those who are
trashing their countries
with poor leadership--
and you've mentioned things
like corruption and cupidity--
they're thinking, ooh.
This isn't somebody who's going
to dictate those things to us.
He wants to talk about trade.
He says his friends have done
some pretty good business
deals in Africa.
That's the sort of
thing they want to hear.
But let's see how
things pan out.
But there are lots of question
marks about the US right now.
I think people are a
little destabilized.
- Everywhere.
All right.
My friends, the
floor is open to you.
The microphone is here.
Please step up and make your
question succinct, please.
- Thank you very much for
this quite inspiring talk.
I brought my students here
from the School of Divinity,
so we are going to talk
about the journalists
as an ethnographer when
we get back next week.
So thanks for that background.
I'd like you to
respond to an issue
that I think is very central
to your conversation.
A group of Africans
are saying that we
don't want the ICC in Hague
to abdicate matters relating
to some of the crisis
that we're faced with.
Governments who are protecting
soldiers who are raping women,
and so on, and so forth.
They are calling
for an African ICC,
and Ghana has been suggested as
a possible place to build it.
So when a person
like you, who is
so passionate about Africa, is
faced with this type of dilemma
of the African identity--
the idea that it
has to be African--
at the same time, we realize
that, at the end of the day,
it's going to be something we
may call police investigation
of police conduct.
Because we are not
sure that justice
would be done if such cases
are brought to an African ICC
court.
So how do you, as a journalist,
deal with similar situations,
or even this particular one?
Caught between
wanting to be faithful
to one's own nation, and
legitimate complaints about ICC
being pretty pro-European?
But at the same time,
knowing fully well that,
if they do this, it's going
to be a serious problem?
What's your response to that?
- I think Africa is
capable of having
its own continental court
to try tyrants, to try
those who violate human rights.
But the problem, I think,
is that African governments
change.
So now, you may have a
quorum, and you may have
leaders who will not interfere.
But what about a few
years down the road?
I know the International
Criminal Court
has issues and has problems.
And there are many criticisms,
especially from Africans,
that it just picks on Africans.
But its justification
is that it has
to be asked by an
African country
to try, say, Laurent
Gbagbo in Cote d'Ivoire.
Then you have those who are
the former president of Cote
d'Ivoire.
You have those who say, well,
they pick on their enemies
and send them to the ICC.
So it's a difficult one.
Because I think we
have come of age.
We have judges who are of
course able to try cases.
Look at the example of Hissene
Habre, the former president
of Chad who was held responsible
for atrocities and war crimes.
That happened at a special
international court
sitting in Dakar, Senegal.
So there are examples
of where it does work.
But whether there is
the continental goodwill
amongst African leaders
is really the issue.
But I'm not sure that
I'm 100% with you
that such an African
court will fail.
I think it has to
be given a chance.
Thank you.
- Hi.
Thank you so much for
being here tonight.
My name is Nick
Diamond, and I've
spent time interviewing
gay men and lesbian
women in Dakar, Senegal.
And I'm wondering if you could
share a little bit of advice
for other journalists,
and those in the room
who are interviewing vulnerable
populations like women
and girls that you spoke
about, in terms of safeguarding
their safety and security
when you're conducting
these types of interviews?
- I think it's really important.
As you know-- you say
you've been in Senegal,
which is a very conservative,
in a positive sense, country--
but when it comes
to LGBT issues,
almost everywhere you go in
Africa, there's pushback.
And especially people saying,
the West can't dictate to us.
We have our own mores.
We have our own values.
And we're going
to stick to them.
And you have countries
like South Africa, that
have very liberal
constitutions, where you have
what they call corrective rape.
Gay women are being
forced to have sex
with men, because they say,
no, women can't be lesbians.
We'll correct it by showing you
that a man can make you happy.
I think it's really important
to keep the identities.
Unless they choose, and
even if they choose,
to speak out in the open.
Because there is such--
I wouldn't say it's hatred.
But there's such
denial on the continent
about almost everything LGBT.
People say, no.
This is un-African.
Why are you bringing
this from abroad?
But those who are willing to
speak out and let people know--
their stories must be told.
But it's not always
going to be possible to--
I know the normal
journalistic routine is
that you give people's names.
But to protect
people's security,
I think it's important
to keep their anonymity,
if it means that they're going
to be in any danger at all.
How long were you in Senegal?
- Nine months.
OK.
Sorry we didn't meet there.
Come back.
- That's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
- Next time.
- Thank you.
- Hi.
I want to thank you both
very much for being here.
And I listen to The
World every day, Marco.
It's wonderful--
- Good.
- --to see you.
- Thank you.
- Last week, I saw
a documentary on HBO
called Queen of the World.
And it was a celebration of
Queen Elizabeth of England,
and the fact that she brings
53 countries, who are part
of the Commonwealth, to the UK.
And the way that this
documentary was slanted,
it was all this big celebration.
And we're all a big family.
And there was no mention
of the exploitative nature
of colonialism, and
imperialism, and racism.
And I was kind of appalled that
it was such an unbalanced film.
So I don't know if you
saw it, but because you
are a daughter of
Ghana, I just would
like to know, what do you
think about the Commonwealth?
And are we drinking
the Kool-Aid here?
[LAUGHTER]
- When you said
Queen of the World,
I thought you were talking
about a documentary,
perhaps of Miriam Makeba?
[LAUGHTER]
- My point exactly.
[APPLAUSE]
- A little reveal here, too.
One of your many
names is Regina.
- Ah.
That's true.
- Your Christian name.
- My Christian name.
- There we go.
- I didn't see it.
I've just got into town.
I think it's good
to maintain links.
Colonialism was
globally bad for Africa.
But some good things,
perhaps, have come out of it.
I'm surprised to hear of a
film that was so uncritical.
- It really
surprised me as well.
I think it's a
British production.
It didn't even seem like
a typical HBO documentary.
I think they probably
just acquired it.
But I'm sure it's
running on on demand.
You should check
it out, because--
[LAUGHTER]
- --but I think--
- I don't consider
Queen Elizabeth
the Queen of the world.
But that's the
name of the show--
- There has to be
a bit of honesty.
The Commonwealth has become,
if not redundant, it's--
I don't know whether
its days are numbered.
But I think it does
some good things.
But how much do Americans know
about the British Commonwealth,
as well as any more--
when we were in the
80s, the Commonwealth
seemed to be quite a
powerful, influential voice.
But it seems to be paring
off and slipping away.
- I wasn't born
under colonialism.
Our forefathers
brought us freedom,
and I'm very grateful for that,
because I've had a good life.
But I think people should
be honest about what went on
during the colonial years.
Reparations?
That's another
question altogether.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
Let me try it this way.
My name is Roberta Logan.
I live in Dorchester, which is
the African-American community
of Boston.
And there are people
who live beyond that,
but I live right in the heart.
And my question-- since you've
spoken well and thoroughly
about the young
women of Boko Haram,
and the young women who have
been affected by rape through
war--
but what are the rest of
the girls thinking about?
What are the girls in
Senegal thinking about?
What are your
nieces and nephews--
well, your nieces--
talking about?
What are their joys?
And what are their concerns?
- They're talking
about becoming coders.
Tech seems to be taking
over the youth in Africa.
They are rapping in
Wolof, or Twi, or Swahili.
Young people are
hugely confident,
which I think is extraordinary.
They feel-- we can be a bit
hangdog when we get to our age.
This and that.
Groaning, moaning.
No, no, no.
They feel their
future is bright.
And they don't feel,
as perhaps in our day,
that it's bright if
you go to the US,
or if you go to Britain,
or if you go to Europe.
Now, China, opportunity knocks.
Or stay right home
and build at home.
They do feel that
they are the leaders.
They feel that it's time for us
to move over and let them take
over, because they feel
confident that they
are the leaders
Africa needs now,
for Africa really
to be propelled
into the 21st century,
in all its magnificence.
So not only young
girls, young boys--
I love talking to them.
I should interview them more.
I was chatting with the
students earlier, and saying,
the voices of young
people are so important.
Because they give me
another perspective
It was like that
parting the waters
to talk to those who
were at the back.
The people at the front
will have one of view.
The young people at
the back will say, no.
You can't speak for us.
Not on this subject.
We know better than you.
So marvelous things happening.
- I could carry
this on for ages,
but I'm going to let
the next person speak.
[LAUGHTER]
- Thank you.
- Hi.
Thank you so much
for all your remarks.
It's been really wonderful
to see you in person.
My name is Sue [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a doctoral student here.
And I also lived in
Senegal for six years.
Nangadef.
- [SPEAKING FRENCH]
- [SPEAKING FRENCH] I'm doing my
research on-- and I think this
is good news--
female parliamentarians in
Senegal and South Africa.
- Female?
- Parliamentarians in
Senegal in South Africa.
And as you know,
across the continent,
because of the quota
systems, number of women
have infused previously
patriarchal governments,
and are starting--
at least my research
is showing--
are starting to make
a difference in terms
of the leadership
in the country.
And here in the
US, we're kind of
on the brink of maybe
a few more women
getting involved
in the government.
But I'm just wondering your
thoughts on female leadership
and in public service in Africa.
Not necessarily the presidents,
but the people who are actually
in the government,
and women's voices
that are in the government,
what your impressions are.
- I would say, government,
one thing, leadership another.
I mean, there's no question
that women make Africa tick.
And they may not make
a big deal about it,
but it's happening,
from market traders,
to those who run businesses,
to those who run homes.
There's no doubt
that it's happening.
But more and more, in the years
I've been covering Africa,
I'm hearing more and
more women's voices,
women speaking out.
Because you've had women
in parliaments all over
for quite a while.
South Africa, as you know.
Rwanda.
Ghana getting a few more.
But often they don't speak out.
It's the men who speak out.
But that is changing.
And not just about issues
of women, and children,
and gender, and so on.
About other issues.
Women are speaking out, and
their voices are being heard.
But they don't always feel that
the public forum is the place
to speak.
They feel that,
sometimes, they're
more influential talking
behind the scenes.
But I think that's changing.
And I think the
younger generation
don't feel that way at all.
They feel their voice is just
as important and must be heard.
So that's a good thing.
Thank you.
- We've got time for one more--
- We've got two people.
- Angola-sized question, or
two Togo-sized questions.
[LAUGHTER]
- Hello.
My name is Bonnie.
I'm an undergraduate at Harvard.
And I was really
excited to hear that you
would be speaking today.
And I'm so glad
that I got to come.
I wanted to ask you about
the economic changes that
have been going on in Africa.
My family is from Ethiopia,
and we got to visit back home
this summer for the first time.
And it was really eye opening
to see a lot of my cousins who--
I have cousins who are
living in urban areas,
and in more rural areas.
And I can see in my family
that lives in more urban areas,
the changes that you
were talking about,
about technology, and the
openness of opportunities,
and the willingness
to stay in the country
and make differences there.
But I was just wondering
if you had anything
to say about the opportunities
available to girls especially
in the rural areas, because
those opportunities are often
more limited, simply because
of logistics, money, and so on,
in a more dramatic way
than they are limited
by the parts of
Africa that are more
urbanized and fortunate in
these growing economic times.
- I can't talk globally,
but I think rural Africa
is an untapped resource.
And I think-- still,
Ethiopia being an example,
although there have been rapid
changes in Ethiopia this year
that people can hardly
believe politically,
which is going to
open up the country--
I think you do have--
because in the countryside,
young boys and girls
are part of farming, for
example, getting them to school
is an issue.
And these days, without
formal education,
it's hard to advance
in the urban areas.
So I think that
is a real problem.
And not just in Ethiopia, in
many African countries where
not only girls, but boys
are not going to school--
although there's meant to
be universal primary school
education-- because they're
needed to tend the fields
or to tend the cattle.
How do we change that?
I think it comes
through leadership.
And it'll be interesting to
see whether, in Ethiopia, that
will change.
Everybody is all smiles with
the new prime minister who seems
to be making a difference.
Reaching out to Eritrea, for
example, and making peace.
But what will it mean
for ordinary Ethiopians
in the long run, especially
people in the rural areas?
I guess we're going
to have to find out.
But it remains a problem.
- I would like to add on, do you
think it would be an economic
solution or a more
education-focused solution?
- I think both.
Thank you.
- And one more.
That was it.
[LAUGHTER]
- Please join me in thanking.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]